Guys for this video. I'm going to show you a cool little survival hack
You can use to make an emergency survival whistle out of an Empty Bullet casing
So let's imagine. You're stranded in the forest
and you need some way to signal for help when you glance down at the forest floor and you just happen to notice one of
These cartridge casings sitting under the branch this shell is from a two to three cartridge
But any long narrow casing like this should work now the first thing
We need to do is actually shave off the tip of this cartridge casing
so we're just left with this fat part at the bottom you can easily do that with some concrete or a
Rock like this and we're going to use that almost as improvised
Sandpaper because what we need to do is sand the brass all the way back to this bigger casing back here
It's going to take a little bit of work
But it is very possible to do now if you're somewhere closer to civilization
You could use concrete to curb on your road or even a paver stone or if you even have some metal files that will work
Better, but the essential idea is we need to shave this back until it gets to about there
It's going to take a few minutes
but eventually you can see we actually get the cartridge casing ground down and there are some little bits inside where you can take a
Sharp rock now and just kind of dig those out to clean it up
We want the inside of that to be as smooth as possible
you can see they're like little flakes of brass in there that need to come off
That's what we're looking for right there the next thing
we need to do is come back about half to three quarters of an inch and grind a small hole in the top in a
Way that there's a flat side on the mouth and and then a gradual sloping side toward the back
Take your casing with the open end
overlapping the edge a little bit and then tilt it a little bit and at that angle we're just gonna run this back and forth
And it's good to take a few minutes
But we want to keep doing this until we dig a hole right through
That side of the casing this is going to be the whistle part of our whistle
Already starting to get a hole through there
You can see it's already starting to take the whistle shape this edge could be a little bit flatter
So I'm going to just adjust my angle a little bit
There we go now all this brass in here
we can just carve that out with a rock or a
Knife or a file or whatever the case may be but we just want to clean up that hole and open it up alright
So that actually went a lot faster than I thought maybe about two minutes
And we got this thing ground down if you look at the profile of this casing though, you can see that
There's a vertical line near the mouthpiece and then a sloping line for at the back of the bullet
That's exactly what we're looking for and there's still a piece on the inside there
But I can use a stick to go down there
And yeah look there's the whole flap right there you might just want to rub it back and forth a few times to clean out
Some of those brass Burrs, but essentially that is our whistle
What I need to do now is find some kind of a stick that will fit perfectly into the front piece here with just enough
of a gap on the top to allow air to flow in and
Split over that whistle on the back all we have to do is a little bit of trial and error until we find a nice
Tight fit and then take a little bit off the top
Now we can use the rock to grind this down to make a flat surface as well
But essentially we're looking for something that will just fit very
snugly inside of that casing the last thing to do is just to trim a little bit of the stick off the tops that we
Have an air gap for our air to flow through and split on the whistle so let's mark that piece right there and then either
File or carve with a knife a little bit off the top just a sliver and that looks good
So now we have to do is break the stick off file it down, and we got ourselves a whistle
Mm fiber
Hey
That sounds amazing so look at the positioning of that see how the wood is actually right on the indent where it starts sloping upward
So right there is a perfect bullet shell whistle that we made with stuff
We found right here in the forest how cool is that guys?
Actually hurts my ears and definitely loud enough to find some help when you're in need in the woods
So there you have a guy is a cool little trick for turning scrap bullet casings into emergency survival Whistles
Thanks so much for joining me for this project, and I'll be looking for you the next video. Talk to you then
you